hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones
final episode ended in ways parallel to
the series origin but in other ways
vastly different and literally 100
percent of viewers were pleased well
done HBO oh weight loss fans are
disappointed huh there's actually a lot
of deeper meaning hidden in the series
closing imagery hinting at big mysteries
for the characters futures and keys
symbolism for how the finale provides
closure to the events of the past eight
seasons so I'm gonna explain what it all
means okay the final montage depicts
epilogues for three characters Jon Snow
Arya Stark and Sansa Stark the editing
that the sequence syncs their action the
close-ups of their primary weapons Jon's
hand on long claw arias hand on the
dagger she killed the night king with
and Sansa's hands slipping through her
new Queen garment embroidered with red
weirwood leaves her steadfast defense of
northern traditions one Sansa this
victory
Sansa becomes Queen at the North which
isn't Queen of all of Westeros but queen
of the only part of Westeros she ever
cared about bran allowed the North to
regain its independence bringing it full
circle with its historical sovereignty
the North was only annexed to the other
kingdoms by the threat of Targaryen
Dragon Fire now that the dragons have
left Westeros the north can go back to
its true status bran may have been
awarded the monarchy at the end of this
series but these final minutes never
show this kind of crowning ceremony for
him brand's reign only really exists as
a solution that the warring factions of
Westeros could live with
whereas sonses crowning is the symbolic
victory that really matters in this
finale bran leaves the ruling of the
kingdom in the hands of Tyrion and the
small Council he plans to use his worgen
abilities to track down Rogan who was
last seen flying the east east to old
Valyria where dragons and Targaryen --zz
once resided or east to the mysterious
shadow lands east of ash I where Danny's
eggs came from it's not certain which
but Brandt's focus is shifting eastward
with drogon like drogon Jon and Aria
this supernatural force is leaving the
drama of Westeros behind Arya shades her
dagger her fighting is done and instead
she fiddles with the telescope and maps
reflecting her future as an explorer
sailing west of Westeros this was a
dream she brought up in season six when
she feared that she would always be
hunted by enemies in Westeros and Essos
Arya is following in the footsteps of
very westeros figures like alisa harmon
who sailed west across the sunset sea on
her ship the Sun chaser discovered three
islands and some believed
circumnavigated this globe to the far
east to the city of a shy Westeros has
been compared geographically to Britain
esos to Eurasia and South rose to Africa
so perhaps west of Westeros or other
continents similar to the Americas Aria
is sailing into the sunset also
parallels the epilogue of Frodo Baggins
and the Lord of the Rings of The Return
of the King Frodo was no longer capable
of finding purpose in this land haunted
by wounds that never healed just like
Aria has outgrown this land still
bearing the scar on her forehead seeking
new shores and new adventures her final
shot echoes the midpoint of this HBO
series the season 4 finale when Aria
last left Westeros hopefully gazing
eastward from the bow of a Braavosi ship
the stark sisters are separated
geographically but they maintain family
unity by both bearing the sigils of how
stark arias bow and sails showed the
direwolf the back of Santa's throne
shows dire wolf heads as well and over
all this the music composed by Ramin
Djawadi is called the last of the Starks
and it blends the House Stark theme with
the main game of Thrones title theme as
if to say this game music that we've
heard at the start of all 73 episodes
now marches to the beat of the Wolves
John joins his sisters in that packed
pride the montage opens with the hilt of
long claw the white wolf head this hilt
was actually in focus the moment John
killed Danny staring down Danny's dragon
head pinned at the dragon and the wolf
United one last time John's choice
brings him back to where he belongs the
north with his direwolf spirit animal
ghost but looking forward what is John's
future where does he go more on John in
a bit but first thanks to our sponsors
Skillshare for helping us make this
episode Skillshare is an online learning
community with more than 25,000 classes
covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills explore classes
and everything from photography creative
writing marketing productivity and more
it's premium membership gives you
unlimited access to high-quality classes
from experts working in their fields to
help you gain new skills and live your
best life to help me sharpen my eye to
analyze the amazing cinematography of
Game of Thrones I tried out the skill
share course cinematography basics
understanding filmmaking style
by Zach Mulligan taught me a lot about
the visual language a shot composition
and camera movement Skillshare is also
incredibly affordable especially when
compared to price the in-person classes
and workshops an annual subscription is
less than ten dollars a month and
because Skillshare is sponsoring this
episode the first 500 people to sign up
with the link in the description will
get a free trial
ok back to John John appears to be Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch once more
and if so after dollar is said as 999th
Lord Commander this might make John the
1,000th Lord Commander depending on
whether they're counting might number of
10 years or number of people either way
according to Tyrion the Nights Watch now
functions as a kind of penal colony a
place for bastards and broken men to
find Redemption this echoes a key theme
of George RR Martin's works the tender
spot for cripples bastards and broken
beams antarians early wisdom to John
never forget what you are the rest of
the world what not I had it like armor
and it can never be used to hurt you
Tyrion applies his logic to brand by
naming him brand the broken repeating
that title over and over again and John
lives on as Jon Snow not his true
identity Aegon Targaryen because his
status as Jon Snow a Night's Watch
bastard was always his armor but despite
John's apparent Lord Commander status he
marches north of the wall with tormund
and the wildlings he may be leading an
expedition or going off to live with
these wildlings leading them like Moses
leading an exodus the final shots show
the gates closing behind him and Jon
fading into the darkness of the forest
as if to never return
Jon's epilogue is by far the most
mysterious he remains a resurrected soul
by the power of the Lord of Light one
who has survived miraculously over and
over since that resurrection that first
shot of Longclaw and the sequence
matches the framing of Longclaw during
John's most insane recovery from the icy
water north of the wall in season 7 so
can Jon ever die is he still even human
and early seasons Jon was obsessed with
finding his uncle Benjen who later was
revealed to have been saved by the
children of the forest who stabbed his
heart with a dragonglass dagger turning
him into this half alive half dead
status kind of like a half measure of
what they did to create the night king
benjin's fate was similar to that of the
night's king from George RR Martin's
books that was the legend
they're a 13th Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch who fell in love with a
woman with skin as white as a moon and
eyes like blue stars this man married
her at the Nightfort declared himself
the night's king and committed various
atrocities like making sacrifices to the
others similar to the human sacrifices
Craster made this night's king was
believed to be half dead half alive so
this could be John's future remember a
part of his punishment was that he would
father no children so maybe his final
journey north is his way of starting a
new bloodline replacing the show's
version of the night king as a kind of
undead supernatural link between life
and death maintaining his vows to serve
as a shield that guards the realms of
men
but north of the wall with descendants
that stay north of the wall whatever
dark future may await John the camera
does not follow him again
John Arya drogon bran these magical
forces exit our worlds and we do not go
with them instead stain on the game
board with us is Sansa Tyrion Davos am
Brienne the others individuals most
focused on the long-term health of
society and reconstruction the closing
scene parallels the opening scene of the
series with many of the shots framed
exactly the same it was the prologue
that introduced the supernatural threat
winter is coming to Westeros this finale
suggests the opposite that those
supernatural elements in winter is
leaving Westeros like a sickness being
cleansed out of a body this resurgence
of hope and new life in Westeros is
symbolized by a close-up of a tiny green
plant poking out of the snow the title
of George RR Martin's final book is a
dream of spring and with this plant the
dream of spring lives on in Westeros
what do you think John's future will be
well comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and on
Twitter at Avis it subscribed into rock
stars thank you for joining me and those
of you who are tweeting me clearly
parody and criticisms like bad writing
and brushed and foreshadowing is no
character development oh my god you
sound so smart
[Music]